o ator diz pessoal daqui quem falou da
área que sejam muito bem vindos e é mais
um vídeo e o estrago já keita e jóias
deixe lá a atenção daqueles jogos que
rasguei agora sentimento há dois dias
atrás a 11 sites em estói meu cd demo é
um sonho e moderno e eu vos gaste tempo
porque e este jogo tem as finais tanto
assustador e luiz questões de clima frio
pra mim você tem vem aí não vou
renunciar e que o manequim o rui porque
eu estou no meio da sala por impedimento
buscai o porto abriu ainda agora com
seis já começam coisas paranormais
acontece no canal ainda não possuía o
jogo rato se jogo e poder obteve o posto
do fred disse omar que enfrenta esta
porta que acontece se você pegar um
solzinho ratton
é isso aí a previsão ficou sua ajuda e
um de mais que favorito o pessoal faça
um estudo apenas foi o dobro portanto
houve uma pobre que não se está do swu
rasgar isto eu não tô primeiro jogo já
aguentei mais 53 projeto e record do
guiness a água do concelho
vamos tentar agora e por esta porta que
é potável por alguém não está agora não
perceber como é que ouvir o que eu acho
que tem a função de estudar florida né
acha cedo para trás já fez na história e
agora o que eu faço eu ficar escondido
atrás do só isso não estou possuído jogo
e não gostou
lanterna o estado forte e é isso que o
futebol ficou confuso e mais jovem de
jogada mais ou menos mas não me importo
sobrevive um mínimo de 25 mil
direito civil sofreu significar morre
enchentes estão que esta coisa não
funciona terá não sei o que está a
passar neste jogo está um estranho
olha só entrou na casa fale agora é
descobrir que hoje se paga uma loja da
fundac meu eu aposto com muita chuva já
conseguiu passar esta morreu não ok
vamos lá planking ajudando ranking em
cinemas bares túnel onde está o tutorial
não há tutela que não há neste look sem
vestir um tutorial foi espreitar aqui
alguém do outro lado não se borra
nenhuma escola de volta atrás
não sei voltar pra eu não sai eu não vou
aí na tecla da wish que já adulto maduro
que não está ninguém aqui está tudo
tranquilo tudo muito fácil já não
consigo aceitar ou não vai bloquear na
bola não dá é completo é possível jogar
eu tenho que eles controlam vamos lá ver
isto vai ser assim só tem sete anos de
idade lhe o domínio no fim do lixão não
tem nada não tem controle
vamos lá tentar agora num na hora já as
encomendas vão entrar em moldar coral
além da rolagem e agora estou
concentrado aqui a única coisa que eu
tenho que fazer é controlar as portas
nem olhar aqui pra baixo e alguém sempre
importante ai ai ai pois comigo
eu saio de carro com muita calma da arca
tudo isso com certo então vamos lá
tentar explicar esta portinha que eu
ainda não vi e não funciona comigo não
funciona nada
alexandre pegou um fox e respeito além
do frete será que está ali há ninguém
para trás vem só agora falta nunca se
voltar atrás de conduta na porta sem luz
eu vi e ouvi eu tinha um piercing no
mesmo segundo ante 34 segundos que
aguentar é impossível este homem o que
estou fazendo errado e quem precisa
explica agora vai ter de aprender vai lá
em cima já sai nesta porta não sei o que
eu quero fazer
foi agora silos estradas há qualquer
coisa que não está a funcionar bem mas
funcionou agora só tem história tem tudo
é tal foxy e oi vai isso já possui um
foco em um jogo pelo aluno que o porto
não tô junto com seu foco em junho eu só
tenho que manter as luzes acesas e
acender a luz à porta em que
supostamente estava animatrónica eu acho
que é isso acho que isso já decorei ou
alguém tá nesta porta alguém está a
briga não é isso pessoal supostamente
isso eu só tenho que manter as duas de
cinzas e incinerar flex nas portas um
dos microfones e parece é isso muito
simples o conceito foi sempre igual aos
outros jogos mas não sabia mexer nos
comandos porque eu sou gay mas sou muito
bem no time e aí o cara branca recebe o
boa o usuário que já sabe ajudar ambos
tinham um dos fiéis na muito político
ela isso foi para trás um padrão eu
tocar este modo o trato corpos mas
quando não funcionam eles não têm
cobertura vai vai ter mais uma só assim
só eu não sabia do caráter não só vai
vir fechado e não quero vos dizer o
quanto antes para atrair e isso
faço quase com ele é dois minutos e 32
muito bom agora muito boxe turbonet tom
da fogueira ok já começamos aqui agora
sob os prédios que não muitas ala brian
de uma apagar as luzes só expresso que
isso agora resulta agora só terá
resultados teclas botafogo agora tá
muito bem o sul sem luz
isso caracteriza a abrir outra luz que
eu fui lá porque porque não acontece
nada já tô aqui pa
agora ainda não condiciona a calma calma
ainda há muito para acontecer é só
esperar o foco ser parceira na época que
ela é chique né ô ô ô já os uso do cloro
e já jantou sozinho
já a mãe aquela ventilação ali é muito
estranha será alguém entre o problema do
fox e assim não sai pode ser que eu
entre volta e isso o indicado da acta
importância dos campos sinto como pessoa
foi o comando foi logo isso meu eu não
sei o que se passou com os comandantes
eu não saí tatá fantasma o gato vai dar
merda eu não vou enganar bobos fahel
ainda mary isso ok sorte que eu tive na
loja sem luz que isso está tudo
controlado agora só está tudo controlado
jato aguentar muito tempo muito tempo e
xix ficou mais raivosa muita calma muita
calma no mundo conhece de controlar eu
acho que já passou mais de dois minutos
e oito câmeras vão principal tudo doido
no twitter que está passado filmes disse
isso ao meu deus estou conseguindo
sobrevivência olha estamos fazendo os
gols
agora sim se jogar no restelo em um
certo ponto um disco domingo 21
agora tudo é é a luz apagou a estudante
precisa estar 100 precisa sendo isso
agora
bota não por jogo
vocês viram só voz é um jogo e eu não
deixava para trás o jogo simplesmente
três minutos e trinta e três
esse é o número de jesus estou bem suave
só vamos lá tentar a última vez que não
tentar bater este tempo não apenas agora
já se jogar eu quero tentar bater cinco
minutos é isso dizer que o pessoal cinco
minutos é tentar aguentar aqui o cara
está tudo tranqüilo e relaxado eu agora
só vou ter que esperar pelo já paga mas
a cena e isso vai logo atrás ninguém é
dado o mote o game mas não pra frente eu
investir assim de luxo o que eu vou
fazer eu espero que o eletrônico e por
isso eu sinta flash lite depois volto e
só podia que os símbolos dessa
estratégia animatronics chega a flash e
photoshop ou em uma armadilha só por
nome
alguma coisa aconteceu além de um visão
houve um barulho não tinha tempo chegou
na porta porque supostamente já tinha
torcida que o boné e agora é só esperar
outra vez não sei se a estratégia certa
né mas vamos tentar assim sul e rodopia
duraã ã justo num jogo 3d e ilan lembra
o importante foi uma das poucas que se
não mostrarem para isso vai mudar que
trata dos frangos dificilmente um site
internet sabe a coisa vai acontecer
agora
a entrada é livre o porto não
conseguiram hoje você ae a foto me choca
me manda focar só metade não poder em
2000 56k lácteo e não só vou ficar com
os filhos para fazer domingo está em
jogo assim recomendaram portanto é comer
demais jogos porque eu gosto que seja um
bom jogo e aí já sabe em quanto você é
que o favorito fimai até a próxima à
gramado